a fire tore through the roof of the
vacant crazy horse 2 nightclub last
night it's located on industrial road
right north of sahara joe mohler shows
us what happened after flames broke out
early this morning
flames could be seen towering over this
building early this morning you can see
the mess on the outside and the damage
to the building people we talked to say
they woke up to the smell of smoke and a
sound of sirens
this is video from just after three
sunday morning dozens of fire crews
responded to the old crazy horse too
fighting it from the ground and above
smoke could be seen all the way in
henderson las vegas fire and rescue
tells us they had to take a defensive
strategy to fight it because of the size
of the flames no injuries were reported
you don't see that every day many many
emergency vehicles all around shane
ducour who lives nearby says he wondered
what was going to happen to this
well-known building it's like are they
going to do anything with that you know
it looks like a big building it looks
kind of
it stands out the now vacant gentlemen's
club had a long well-known history one
of the former owners rick rizzolo sold
the property after it was raided by the
fbi back in 2003 he pled guilty to
failing to pay payroll taxes he was
known for suspected mob ties the federal
government owned the building for some
time before it was sold the club has sat
empty for many years many wondering what
would happen to her fire crews were out
here for much of the morning putting out
hot spots investigators are still trying
to determine the cause reporting near
the strip joe muller live local now